hallo klicks um hallo herr renneberg
meine beiden fragen wären könnten unsere
atomkraftwerke an erdbeben ab stärke 5
überhaupt überstehen
die deutschen kernkraftwerke sind gegen
erdbeben ausgelegt die frage ist nur
sind sie gegen die erdbeben ausgelegt
die tatsächlich
vorkommen können
das wird dann jeweils so bestimmt dass
man jeden einzelnen standort an cook vor
dem kernkraftwerk weil es ja ein
unterschied ob ein kernkraftwerk in
schleswig holstein liegt oder im
oberrheingraben in schleswig holstein
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit von stärkeren
erdbeben wesentlich kleiner als im
oberrheingraben deswegen werden da auch
verschiedene erdbeben zu grunde gelegt
diese kernkraftwerke dann auch
überstehen müssen und am oberrheingraben
überstehen die kernkraftwerke ein
erdbeben der stärke 5 ohne weiteres es
hat auch schon solche erdbeben gegeben
zwar nicht direkt im oberrheingraben
aber da kann ich mich daran erinnern da
wohnte ich in wiesbaden unter wackelte
das bett und die lampe fing an zu sich
zu bewegen das war ein relativ starkes
erdbeben es war über
5,54 glaube ich über einen belgien und
strahlte bis in diese gegenden ab da ist
auch nichts passiert die frage ist nur
sind das die stärksten erdbeben die
auftreten können und da beginnt der
streit
es gibt eine bedeutende es gibt viele
die sagen das was im oberrheingraben an
annahmen gemacht worden ist das ist viel
zu schwach die müssen ja viel stärker
ausgelegt werden
deswegen ist es jetzt auch notwendig
nach jetzigen erkenntnissen also das was
man jetzt weiß gegenüber dem was man 40
jahren mal angenommen hat noch mal zu
überprüfen ob das alles stimmt und ob
die erben auslegung der kernkraft
ausreichend ist
eigentlich möglich
theoretisch kann man die kühlsysteme in
vieler weise verbessern und auch da gibt
es bedeutende unterschiede zwischen den
neueren kraftwerken und den älteren
kraftwerken gerade die älteren
kraftwerke
sind entsprechen nicht dem was man heute
nach dem stand von der technik bei den
kühlsystemen alles vor versehen würde
beispielsweise hängt das schon damit
zusammen dass die rohrleitungen nicht
aus dem stahl sind dem man heute
verwenden würde man hat
in den neueren kraftwerken mehr
kühlflüssigkeit unsere in reserve die
kühlsysteme sind auch zuverlässiger in
den neueren kraftwerken also da könnte
man bei den alten kraftwerken eine menge
tun aber sowohl bei den älteren
kraftwerken in deutschland wie auch bei
den neueren kraftwerken gibt es immer
eine möglichkeit dass das auch versagen
könnte und es gibt auf der welt kein
einziges kraftwerk bei dem man sagen
kann
ja die kühlung funktioniert immer das
gibt es nicht und das ist genau das was
die sicherheit heute beschreibt die
grenzen der sicherheit beschreibt so
etwas kriegt man mit 100 prozentiger
sicherheit auch nicht hin es gibt heute
neuentwicklungen die werden in finnland
da wird in finnland ein kraftwerk gebaut
und in frankreich 1 die haben noch
zusätzliche systeme für den fall der
jetzt in schuhen in japan ein tritt
nämlich für den fall dass es tatsächlich
eine kernschmelze gibt und so ein heiße
lava von kernschmelzen masse
durchschmilzt durch den
reaktordruckbehälter haben die noch die
möglichkeit das zu verteilen und zu
kühlen um zu verhindern dass es dann aus
dem sicherheitsbehälter dann heraus
tritt in die umgebung das ist natürlich
eine zusätzliche sicherheit aber auch
diese systeme die dafür jetzt eingebaut
werden auch die können versagen insofern
gibt es auch da keine hundertprozentige
sicherheit aber richtig ist man kann
eine menge daran tun man kann eine menge
verbessern wenn man das aber bei den
alten kernkraftwerken jetzt auch
abgeschaltet sind machen würde dann
würde sich der betrieb von denen nicht
mehr lohnen